what do we know about the circumstances
of this event in Florida yeah the Teslin
was going down a double highway a
two-lane multiple Highway and a
tractor-trailer took a left in the
attesa la Nile pod the auto pilot didn't
see the tractor-trailer it's white
siding against the bright sky and it
didn't stop and ran right into the side
of the truck actually going underneath
of it and in that the driver died you
know so the if officials are still
investigating the cause of it and the
the question is going to be whether the
actual driver would be able to stop in
time and whether the technology should
have been able to see that
tractor-trailer it's do we know Tim
whether there have been other complaints
about Teslas on autopilot
perhaps not leading to fatalities but
also accidents well when this technology
was was ruled out a last fall there
immediately with some interesting
YouTube videos of people doing rather
silly and foolish things with autopilot
on you know they used to you could see
people getting in the back of their car
as the car continued to drive down the
street and they made some changes in
early January to make it a little less
reckless and in fact the driver is
really in charge of the vehicle is
supposed to keep his or her hands on the
wheel and if they take them off for a
long period of time the car actually
will start beeping and eventually slow
and so when the driver gets in they are
still the driver still responsible this
is not fully autonomous this is not the
Google car or the robot car of the
future that does all the work there this
is more like advanced cruise control
that keeps the car in the lane and
allows the car to brake or slow or speed
up depending upon the settings Tim why
isn't the stock down more well I mean so
what some of the details are coming out
is I looked through the Highway Patrol
report here the accident report you know
one of the interesting things is that
the tractor-trailer was there was didn't
yield is so the investigation will be
into who's responsible but one of the
questions is going to be who is who is
ultimately at fault here if this was
just a normal accident where the driver
been able to stop
that's that said that this has been one
of the concerns in the engineering
community is that what would happen
after the first fatality
in a totally autonomous car because as
they as they would point out in evitable
II was going to happen somebody was
going to die if you look at just normal
driving people die on a routine basis
and they've been making the argument
that hey this this technology would be
at least safer perhaps and maybe reduce
those kind of accidents Tim I want to
ask about going beyond Tesla because all
the auto companies are experimenting
with it telling us driving and
particularly Cadillac is supposed to
come out with a similar sort of a
modified itano's Dramamine early next
year
what possible ramifications does this
have for the GM's the Fords the other
auto companies well what's so remarkable
about Tesla's technology is that they
just brought it out and it essentially
surprised the market whereas GM has been
talking about and working on it for a
very long time and in fact delayed
bringing it out saying they were gonna
bring out when it was ready so there's
that issue but also the the broader
concern among some and the auto and tech
space is that any kind of death would
delay you know make the public less
confident in the technology and attract
more regular regulation and regulators
interest in this kind of thing safety
advocates have been saying there they're
just this isn't ready yet